what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today to watch
the next trailer for Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania of course got my
co-host John with me join but Andrew the
Gordon Andrew say hi to everyone hi
everyone
Spider-Man reference to see what we did
there citizen king shirt shops or
edition.com real rejects exclusive
anyway we
leave a like that helps out the video
all right let's see what new stuff is in
store today inside of movies that were
like right around the corner let's go
[Music]
foreign you're an interesting man
Scotland I hear a king you're an Avenger
you have a daughter
but you've lost a lot of time
like me
make it a proposal here we could help
each other with that
yeah don't do it Scott damn
who are you
I'm the man who can give you the one
thing you want
[Music]
I can rewrite existence
and shatter timelines wow
oh
this could be awesome oh is that Morocco
wow
he can give us a second chance he looks
like a big Corey stole him oh no
flying Stingray the way of quite easy
for you
or everything you call a life will end
this looks epic yeah wow the biggest
Ant-Man movie yet
oh the Ant-Man may not want her to watch
this we had a deal
he's gonna get his ass kicked
punch him in the face
POV
I don't have to win
I can do this all day
oh dang wow
I'm sorry Cassie
oh
[Music]
wow what an epic trailer glorious
that's a glorious trailer okay wow
that's a lot to digest right there
there's so much to digest right there
I'm loving the setup of this movie so
far of Kane coming in being like hey
I'm actually a good guy I'm here to help
you Scott I can get you time back and
then over the course of time as this
movie plays out discovering no wait he's
actually a terrible human being he's got
some devious plans at least the way the
trailer is going about it it would imply
that Janet definitely knew who Kane was
already and had experiences with King
Parker she's like not dumping a bunch of
exposition but at least explaining some
stuff here and it looks like when they
get into the quantum realm that Scott
and Janet are separated from Scott
Cassie you know she's not there to warn
them about King while they're
interacting with gang and it's sort of
building up to that before Scott learns
the truth about all this beyond that man
there were just so many like crazy
visuals throughout it looks like he's
going to be exploring all different
kinds of scotlings and all different
like the Multiverse Contraptions would
you call this multiversion the quantum
verse Contraptions but I thought this
was a a beautiful epic perilous trailer
and and Kang looks awesome this looks
this looks really really awesome and
more of the Multiverse Saga that we've
been hoping and waiting for John what
did you think of Modoc and the giant
Corey stole head that's right I'm
excited to see this ridiculous character
coming to live action on screen and yeah
I mean just the array of I mean not only
yeah King Ant-Man but the things that
await in the quantum realm that we are
going to see more of than we ever have
before like this does feel someone's
gonna make that joke it's the smallest
movie but it also looks like one of the
bigger ones and I think that's really
cool and I think it also this looks
intense and harrowing like this looks
like us this will hit the fields but in
a sort of desperate kind of way like I
just get a foreboding sense from this
trailer and I love that they're pitching
Kang like a guy who is you know who is
not a villain villain he's clearly got a
plan and he wants to mutually benefit
one another but you're gonna come to
that crossroads where the ideology is
too severe year and I can already feel
the emotional weight of the choices
Scott's gonna have to make it's cool to
come out of an Ant-Man trailer with the
weight instead of just like oh cool fun
and games and size switching and stuff
you know that's all going to be there
this looks hardcore man this looks like
we could be saying goodbye to some
people and I'm sad about it maybe maybe
I mean it looks like that uh he might
have a a bone to pick with Janet himself
actually Andrew what'd you think it was
a interesting trailer I think everyone's
biggest question was where's Bill Murray
uh that's what everyone
exactly
visually it looks really dazzling I
remember an Ant-Man and the WASP uh the
second film I really enjoyed the limited
amount of time we got to spend in the
quantum realm so I'm really looking
forward to just a movie that's based
around actually being in the quantum
realm and just from what we've seen in
the couple trailers we've gotten looks
really trippy looks acidy looks visually
uh intense also I gotta mention not to
get into DC here but that shot where
King like just broke uh ant-man's uh
visor it really reminded me a lot of the
Dark Knight Rises where after Bane kind
of you know crashed the cow I was
getting some Vibes there just like he's
about to take a major beating obviously
we could see visually but I think that
really intrigued me the most on top of
seeing uh Cassie and their stature uh
was I really am very curious to see
Modoc from the origin of the character
in 1967's uh uh Tales of uh of suspense
uh or you uh got it you got it issue
number 90 issue number 93. I thought it
was you know the characters are really
compelling character and then in modox
11 in 2007 we really got to see the
backstory in the origin I don't know if
they're gonna have time in this film to
go into the origin story of that
character George tarlington although it
looks like maybe Darren cross is
possibly being the character now but
looks exactly like it
but either way the character is really a
compelling character he's got an
interesting backstory again I don't know
if they're gonna have time in this film
with all the moving Parts all the
characters and everything all the
storylines that are happening but I
really hope at some point if it's not in
this film I hope at some point in the
MCU and modoc's Future appearances I do
hope they go into the backstory because
again he's a very emotionally invested
character he's got a very sympathetic
backstory and I'm hoping you know the
general going audience who doesn't know
Modoc very well I'm hoping they get to
see that done properly on the big screen
I think it'll be uh somewhere in the
middle here I'm sure yeah I imagine I'll
go Full Tilt I mean it looks like he's
working for King at first but at the
same time I wonder if they're gonna do
some type of complexity uh issue with
him as like oh maybe I should be helping
them out especially if it is just the
Darren cross who's become Modoc and he
might it's either gonna be something
where he really wants to get back at
Scott or he might have some type of
change of heart I'm not exactly sure
what they'll do a mode up but I'm
surprised they gave us even just the I
always wanted him a couple of times here
in the trailer but to get those two
glasses and I think the other thing
about it is the heart of the movie will
be between Cassie and Scott from what it
appears you know looks like that he's
feeling so much remorse and guilt over a
you know from the first Ant-Man movie
you saw how he just wanted to be a dad
and he couldn't be a good had because he
was too busy being a criminal and then
he then he lost out on time with her uh
with the with the blip and all that and
if I feel like that'll be the ultimate
wrap around with this movie of him
making some type of amends with her now
that she's all grown up and she's all
smart and it seems like he's doing his
own career path while she's doing her
own Journey he's not even really
involved with and this mission that they
go through this life experience might
bring some type of resolve with them uh
by the end of it all so I feel like it's
got a lot of heart it's called Quantum
verse therapy yeah that's what it is
absolutely and then we're probably gonna
get a big explanation with Janet too I I
feel like they have a she's got to have
some type of history with hang here yeah
that seems like all the biggest
implications because that's also got to
be not only do you have the direct
physical stakes and her warnings from
before but I can also see that as
something that maybe draws some kind of
divide between the pims and the Langs
yeah in the process especially because
it seems like Scott is very inclined to
take the this deal and get that time
back well yeah I mean you're talking
about desperate earlier and it feels
like not only is Scott desperate for
something what a great a great Primal
feeling for a king to prey on uh but
also like Kang looks desperate like he's
been trapped here forever yeah and he'll
pray on this one sucker and get my way
out yeah man I'm a prisoner but yeah I'm
also looking forward to to stature like
maybe how she gets her powers possibly
in the quantum realm because as we saw
in the second film Michelle Pfeiffer's
Janet van dime she has that healing
ability from the quantum realm where
she's able to heal ghost so I'm very
curious to see is that how she gets her
powers as stature or is it going to be
more like in the comics where after
spoiler Scott Lang dies she you know she
honors her father and she takes like the
pen particles and that's how she gets
her power there so I'm kind of curious
which way they're gonna go if she's
going to get it from the quantum she
already has a suit yeah yeah but I mean
I'm just curious if she's going to get
some kind of a power though like Jana
van like outside of the suit yeah
comfortably just from the quantum realm
so I'm kind of curious to see what's
going to happen there it's just again
just the it's visually dazzling what I'm
seeing from the quantum realm and to me
I mean I always like to go see an IMAX
movie anyways but like just from the
quantum realm scenes like this kind of
Demands and I actually I saw Avatar in
3D on IMAX and they played the trailer
for the for the first one in 3D and it
is IMAX formatted and I was like oh this
actually looks beautiful and worth
watching in 3D and yeah this looks um
you know what yeah I think for everyone
who had issues with phase four I'm
getting a feeling this is going to turn
things around yeah
I'm really getting the feeling this is
going to turn some [ __ ] around all right
guys what did you think about the
trailer leave your thoughts down below
thank you Andrew for being here John you
did your part yep subscribe leave a like
and hey hey we'll catch you all soon
foreign